let me ask you what does your husband do
for work
uh he is a personal trainer personal
trainer but he also does he plays a
guitar yeah and he does only where does
he make all his money is it mostly only
fans it's both both uh training and and
only was there ever a point in your guys
marriage where his he wasn't bringing
home the bacon yes
and how did that work because like
everything you're saying the sex the
great it's life i love him i love but
like it was hard it was hard i'm i'm not
gonna lie um
for a long period of time well it wasn't
a long period of time but enough uh two
years that's long yeah i was the main
breadwinner yeah um and
you know what i i would not undo it
because it has taken a relationship to
where it is today um i wouldn't undo it
and i don't blame anybody for not being
the breadwinner or a man not making
money i do but
but as a woman it is very hard because
on top of everything and your emotions
and everything and everything being a
woman on top of that you also have to go
out and make the money yeah yeah which
is very hard what was the most difficult
conversation like in in the in
the throes of the depths of disparity
even then having to confront the man is
like oh yeah exactly no i didn't have an
issue with it i i literally what changed
was the pandemic
okay um well it wasn't really the
pandemic i kind of went and said listen
this is my my only fans i can't run in
myself i have 600 unread messages on
there this was like in the beginning
can you help me at least like make a
daily schedule for me you know stuff
so i can just concentrate on answering
myself this is when you were crushing it
with only fans and he was yeah
unemployed not working
so what happened was he became a
personal trainer right yeah the pandemic
happened
and he lost his job yeah oh wow because
it like all the equinoxes closed and he
you know he was well he wasn't out of
the job but he could come back with all
the masks all the everything you know
and he was like i just don't want to do
it because it's just too hard so the
bottom line is you have to have a
difficult conversation with him 600
unread messages i need you here buddy
yeah so i was like can you just help me
with my other social medias like can you
help me
maybe do a daily schedule for me or help
me take pictures help me film help me
edit yeah so
i'm a team player yeah exactly so i can
just take over and answer my 600
messages because on top of the 600
unread messages i had to do the filming
the editing the posting like everything
plus going to the club why aren't you
outsourcing
because
so i still want to run my own only fans
i wanted to be me answering the messages
i wanted to be me posting my stuff i
didn't want anybody else to do it
because that's just not personal
but if somebody could help me with
everything around your husband
responding to other guys on only fans oh
no god no no
hey brother how are you doing great bro
what to do no he has his own only fans
for that when did he start that uh his
own only fans he started that uh
probably a year ago yeah sauce let me
ask you something though for me if i'm
not
the the main breadweather that eats me
up yeah i totally did i mean i i'm
probably i'm i'm not discrediting him
but i'm just saying is that for you well
this is the laws of hypergamy right i
mean this is like all right no i don't
i've never dated a girl that has made
more than me it hasn't happened and i've
when given those opportunities like for
instance some guy was like a buddy of
mine was like i want to connect you with
this girl
she's like the biggest realtor in miami
i think you guys would hit it off i
looked at her i was like
yeah i don't know i don't i don't number
one i wasn't that that attracted to her
okay i guess here's the answer the
question if i was super attracted to her
i don't care if she was the worst
realtor miami or the best realtor but
the fact that i was like marginally
attracted to her
it did nothing for me that she's some
big time realtor nothing it would have
actually annoyed me yeah exactly you
know
is this hypergamy or were you going with
this i mean [ __ ] hypergamy i'm just
saying in general like as a man like
okay i'll tell you a story in 2018 i
quit my corporate job in tokyo to go
full time on youtube and launch my
business and it was [ __ ] hard right
it was really bad
i remember one time i went to the beach
with my girlfriend
and um
i couldn't buy the forty dollar dinner i
didn't i just didn't have forty dollars
and she was like and she was like this
is in 2018 2018. okay so things have
turned around since the pandemic for you
slightly
good for you so but dude that [ __ ]
burned into me for like months the fact
that she had paid 40. and it's not that
she wasn't like oh here you are you
loser she was totally sweet kind loving
the best girl i've ever been with my
life
um but as a man just for me personally
like i
cannot
not be the breadwinner that's just me
personally and i i talk to my guys too
like dude it it's awesome to be the
[ __ ] boss and girls love it like we
have a you know she's like telling you
right here like she loves serving her
man she loves him being in charge and
that's what a lot of power dynamics in
the united states are like
wrecking relationships because they're
telling men oh like you need to be more
feminine you need to be in touch with
feminine side it's okay to be
stay-at-home dad and then the women like
oh you'll go be boss babe go be a ceo
and stuff and like both of the genders
are [ __ ] miserable when they follow
this [ __ ] advice so if you like that
clip click right here to watch another
or if you want to watch the entire sauce
cast click right here
[Music]